hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to teach you a math magic
trick of how you can multiply any
three-digit number by 7 then 11 and then
13 in your head here's how the trick
works you call out a spectator and have
them pick any three digit number that
they want and you're going to do some
quick mental math so you ask them to
take out a calculator and multiply the
number by seven they don't tell you the
intermediate result then you have them
multiply it by 11 and you then tell them
go ahead and multiply the number by 13
even before they can read the answer on
their calculator you're going to call
out the answer so let's do an example of
how this trick works let's say you have
a spectator the spectator picks out the
number 123 so on their calculator
they're multiplying by seven then 11 and
13 and you already know the answer is
123123 if the spectator calls out 457
then you look like you're doing some
mental calculation but you already know
the answer is four hundred and fifty
seven thousand four hundred and
fifty-seven
so this is a trick you can only do once
the pattern is very simple if the number
is ABC after multiplying by seven and
eleven and thirteen the answer will
always be ABC ABC and there's a reason
for this it's because seven times 11
times 13 is 1001 and that's what you get
when you multiply any three-digit number
by a thousand and one I hope you like
this video please subscribe to my
channel you can support me on patreon to
get exclusive rewards catch me on my
blog miner decisions on Twitter at
pressure Locker and you can get my books
listed on my website